this is a story of finance gone wrong
the credit suisse story is a story of
one of switzerland's most important
institutions one of the most important
banking institutions in europe the bank
which ignored risks ignored red flags we
are in a very challenging situation we
need to address that
there is a cultural issue at the bank
good financial result at any price it's
a tale of scandal after scandal but at
certain points during this has gotten
quite hard to believe you have bulgarian
drug smugglers oligarchs general chaos
at one of the world's top wealth
managers and investment banks a bank
that used to be a national pride now
trying to recover from that smp global
downgraded great swiss cg you have taken
very decisive steps
credit suisse let its commercial team
override its risk team and what we're
seeing now is historic scandals but also
some more recent scandals it's just
created the basket case bank of europe
let's roll back the clock to 1856 alfred
escher the 19th century industrialist
he's looking to modernize switzerland he
sets up his own bank we know today as
credit suisse what a lot of people maybe
outside of switzerland don't quite
understand is just how integral credit
suisse is to the the history of
switzerland i'm acceleman chairman
criticized group since january this year
banking is really part of the fabric of
switzerland and criticism was very
instrumental to the economic success of
switzerland it's a big honor to be asked
to share such a great organization with
that legacy i mean credit suisse is
fundamentally at its core a private bank
it's a bank that caters to very rich
individuals so the central cog is the
wealth management business and this
really is the driving engine for the
bank it provides financial services it
provides advice and it helps protect the
the wealth of the world's richest people
connected to that cog are the asset
management business which invests a lot
of those funds the investment bank which
is tied not only will they manage their
wealth but they'll help them run their
businesses they'll help them provide
financing loans help them with ipos
listing their companies and then you
also have the swiss domestic bank it's a
a global organization with these
components that interlock together
governance and risk management is
essential
where we have all these different
services provided to customers which may
create conflicts of interest
a huge amount of the world's very
wealthy uh have relationships with swiss
banks switzerland has a long history of
the rule of lord the swiss franc is very
stable switzerland has its historic bank
secrecy laws clients can be guaranteed a
huge amount of discretion combine that
with its steadfast neutrality through
multiple world wars then there is also
of course the concierge concept of swiss
banking you will be looked after they're
luxury venues all of that is a package
that they use to lure the super rich
in zurich you have two main banks you've
got credit suisse and you've got ubs
credit suisse has for in me certain
years played the junior partner but
actually credit swiss is within
switzerland seen as much more of the
swiss national bank
the clue is in the name and it is quite
literally the bank of switzerland
and if you go to zurich right in the
center the parada plat square there are
its two major financial institutions
literally meters from each other
kerry swiss is innovative bit more
aggressive probably also more
risk-taking ubs is much more structured
more boring but also less risky credit
suisse on a relative scale was probably
one of the least effective banks by the
financial crisis ubs was the bad boy it
had to be bailed out they had insider
trading scandals there wasn't the
requirement on them to really face up to
a lot of the problems that had emerged
in the run-up to financial crisis in the
immediate years afterwards it's almost
as though they didn't get the memo in
2008 when we had the last banking crisis
we've seen many banks rehabilitate and
change how they operate credit squeeze
has not
early 2019 and the cogs really start to
come loose at credit suisse
the chief executive at the time tjan
tiam is a debonair gregarious
international financial celebrity one of
the people he brought in was a former
auditor from ey iqbal khan hyper
ambitious but the two men whether it was
tijan tiam's leadership style or iqbal
khan's vaulting ambition
started to fall out
iqbal khan had bought the house directly
next to tijantian on the so-called gold
coast of lake zurich and proceeded to
knock the entire thing down anyone
that's had had a neighbor with
construction work knows how annoying
this is but it's particularly annoying i
think when it's one of your subordinates
and the work is consistently going on
even on saturdays
and they're building a bigger house than
you so tijan tiam accused iqbal khan of
building a big window which looked into
his lounge and in response
planted some rather large trees blocking
mr khan's view of lake zurich the two
men's partners got into a bit of an
argument and it very nearly came to
blows khan was poached by ubs usually
when a big banker or wealth manager
leaves
they have a long period of gardening
leave you are not allowed to work you're
not allowed to talk clients you're not
allowed to poach staff and zurich is a
small town you can walk across it in
about 25 minutes so it's impossible not
to bump into clients customers potential
hires someone at credit suisse decided
to hire a spying firm these people
started following around iqbal khan and
he noticed he stopped his car in the
center of zurich and confronted them
this is something that usually you watch
on tv cars following another car and and
this is something not in swiss
culture a lot of this was around the
bickering between iqbal khan and
tijuantia doing unably things to each
other and i think that probably struck a
lot of swiss as being deeply
inappropriate and not discreet
conservative it emerged that iqbal khan
wasn't the only person credit suisse had
had tails
this eventually led to the ousting of tj
antiem in spring 2020. step forward
thomas gottsteen a safe pair of hands
really he's of course swiss he'd been in
charge of the universal bank here which
i guess is the most boring and stable
part there was certainly a lot of
negative press and but i think that's
behind us now and we're really looking
forward now to
continuing on the successful
part within three weeks of gottsteen
taking over switzerland was forced into
lockdown thomas scottsdean said he
wanted 2021 to be a clean slate
2021 however would turn out to be one of
the most tumultuous times in credit
suisse's 166 year history his promise
was completely in tatters you had these
two mega scandals that from a financial
point of view were vastly more relevant
than the spygate affair
disaster struck at the beginning of
march 2021 credit suisse had been
persuading its wealthiest clients to
invest in a suite of funds known as the
green seal supply chain funds greenster
was very heavily linked to an
industrialist sanjeev gupta but also
softbank the huge japanese technology
slash speculative investor
not all of the deals that were going
down were entirely above board
allegations of fraudulent invoices
circular financing they're the mass 10
billion of funds from these wealthy
clients and the promise was put your
money in here it's very safe
early 2021 all of the supply chain
finance stuff around lex green seal
sanjeev gupta and softbank starts to
unravel the bonds that credit suites
investors
had been persuaded by the wealth
management unit to invest in were not
going to get paid back something as
prosaic as insurance policies coming to
an end brought these funds to a
staggering halt that was a trigger to
the collapse underlying that were
investments in risky future receivables
they were investing in the bet that
those monies would be paid over and
credit suisse was forced to suspend them
locking in 10 billion dollars worth of
their clients assets and unleashing one
of the biggest scandals in credit
suisse's history it's about 2.3 billion
of this 10 billion is unaccounted for we
are acting um on behalf of investors in
greensville um who made their investment
through credit suisse to recover losses
suffered
it's not going to dip into its own
reserves to pay the customers it was
sold to
these are long-standing clients of
credit suisse in many cases i speak to
some of these clients they are furious
and they think they've been lied to
these are powerful people credit suisse
had a separate relationship with
greenster and was courting it in
relation to its ipo and there's an
argument to be had that blinded it
just as credit suisse was reeling from
this it lurched from one crisis to the
next this time 3000 miles away in new
york
bill huang's family office archegos
capital bill huang had made oversized
bets on a few stops using enormous
leverage
from the so-called prime brokerage
businesses of a number of global banks
none of the banks knew quite how much
leverage bill huang had
it's actually 160 billion lots of banks
were caught in this morgan stanley ubs
credit suisse was left nursing 5.5
billion dollars worth of losses its
biggest trading loss in its entire
history it sent its share price tumbling
regulators were pouring all over it its
clients were preparing lawsuits against
it and this obviously raised all kinds
of questions how the bank's different
cogs were fitting together
[Music]
bill huang had strong relationships with
some of the bank's top executives from
asia
through to the uk credit suisse was
really bending over backwards to please
him to give him more leverage through
its investment bank in order to run more
of his money a credit loss of such a
magnitude to a single party highlights
indeed deficiencies in risk management
so the bank spirals further down into
crisis it has to raise capital from its
long-suffering investors the bank has to
publish an absolutely excoriating
report from an external law firm the
report showed stunning deficiencies and
yes this reflects risk culture
which credit suisse now clearly says has
to change problematic client
relationships within wealth management
prime broking and investment banking
businesses can spiral out of control if
you don't have the right
culture you don't have the right
procedures and you don't have the right
technology in place it is a very deep
rooted issue which really needs time to
be solved credit suisse needs to draw a
line under this scandal it needs to hire
a heavy hitter to replace embattled and
i think at this point discredited
chairman erz rohner
so they turned to a big deal banker sir
antonio horta osorio who was knighted
for his turnaround of lloyd's bank after
the financial crisis in the uk the idea
was that aho as he is often known in the
industry would cut a lot of risk which
really harmed its ability to generate
returns this was seen as the medicine
that was required
i am vincent kaufman i am the ceo of the
esos foundation created by two swiss
pension funds to promote sustainable
investment we do represent at a credit
suisse general meeting between three to
five percent we were a bit surprised we
were expecting someone from the maybe
the swiss economy but then we look at
these cvs it's track records and we said
that's not a bad idea a good person with
a very good knowledge of the private
bank and wealth management less on the
investment bank and that was for
something we also always push reduce
this exposure to investment bank to
risky assets antonio is portuguese
he is very talented and he knows this
but he's not swiss this can always be a
problem as tijan tian found out tijan
tian was criticized for being aloof
imperious enjoying the jet set lifestyle
too much and that was always going to be
a danger for horto rosario his downfall
came about from a combination of his
hubris self-confidence the way he
alienated himself from his executives
and his board but also taking the
company's private jets for his own
personal uses the sheer number of trips
he's been taking to lisbon which is not
a major revenue earner it's pretty
obvious he's he's using the private jet
to go home a lot
at the heart of the covid lockdowns he
flew into london to attend on the same
day the wimbledon tennis finals and that
very evening watched england lose on
penalties to italy in the european
championship final
by doing so he had contravened the uk's
covid rules as a new chair you want to
change the culture
you have to be free of any any any
scandals and repetitional issues when
you start violating uh rules yourself
then we have a major issue there was a
kind of sense that here was yet another
outsider being brought in to try and
change or manage credit suisse but who
had moral failings and ultimately he had
to go and the bank is backing crisis
again
one of the main scandals that reflected
tijantian's time at credit suisse was a
terrible incident where some of their
staff collaborated with a middleman and
a russian bank vtb to sell
three billion of bonds to the country of
mozambique ostensibly to build a fleet
of amphibious warfare vehicles to
protect a separate fleet of tuna fishing
boats but a significant amount of this
money was embezzled by the various
bankers involved the middlemen
and local officials we're actually on
behalf of bondholders who are suing
credit suisse in connection with bonsai
arranged and issued in favor of
mozambique the debt is unpaid and undue
and owing and it stands at 200 million
so credit suisse has settled with all
three regulators that investigated it
the uk the us and switzerland we're
talking a really big deal here it was
around 11 billion
in part because all world aid was
withdrawn and they significantly
suffered as a consequence of that and 11
billion dollars translates to around 400
dollars per individual so a country that
was already struggling really really
struggles significantly as a consequence
2022 has been a long way from the clean
slate that gotsteen promised a year
earlier beneath that very respectable
service and all of those kind of marble
lobbies and very smart entrance ways
there have been a whole series of
dubious dealings over the years
credit suisse has been in this
long-running dispute over allegations
that it helped a bulgarian former
wrestler run his international cocaine
smuggling ring here was a case that was
removing the cover so that we could see
the kind of inner mechanics and the way
that the the bank had functioned over
many years and how risk management or
anti-money laundering practices were
really completely irrelevant this was
historic of course in 2004 and 2007. the
details are shocking their due diligence
for their clients is putting bulgarian
news articles into google translate and
attempting to read them what was really
crucial was protecting the secrecy of
clients even to the point where
headlines about assassinations drug
smuggling weren't enough to dissuade
risk management from continuing to take
money from those clients and it just
raises the question how many other
clients like this do they have it looks
like in emerging countries where uh
there is absolutely no regulation
criminal uh involved um and money
laundering at this at this level is
unbelievable just as they're reeling
from accidentally financing a cocaine
smuggling ring
they get hit by another one of these
global data leaks
so-called swiss leaks data dump this
detailed lots of cases where the bank
had previously offered a sanctuary to
dirty money flowing around the world
from family members of kleptocrats and
oligarchs corrupt government officials
and criminal organizations unwanted
links to potential human trafficking
embezzlement creditors confirmed ninety
percent of those accounts are now closed
since 2015. there is still ten percent
of the accounts which are still under uh
scrutiny so esos
at the general meeting 2022 requested a
special audit on this uh offer swiss
leagues and on the on the green seal
affairs because of course the board is
requesting internal investigation but
they pay the inverter in internal
investigation and can decide what they
want to publish or not publish because
for the greenseed case they decided not
to publish the investigation the
regulator here finma say that they take
a very hard line but crucially it all
goes on behind closed doors it's very
hard to get a sense of whether the swiss
are taking it seriously or not they say
oh don't worry finma is doing his work
so as investors shareholders or
stakeholders of the bank we don't have
any clue of what
happened a further blow comes the former
prime minister of georgia has been suing
credit suites in the caribbean with zina
even ishvali a client of a rogue private
banker who had fleeced a whole load of
incredibly wealthy people out of their
savings and and funded a lavish
lifestyle of rolex watches and fast cars
credit swiss had had always played the
card that this was a rogue banker and
nothing to do with them and he wins he
wins a huge judgment against them and
the bank is suddenly booking a massive
impairment blowing a hole in its latest
quarterly results and to capital off
credit swiss is facing investigations
from regulators in switzerland and the
us
looking at a deal it struck at the end
of 2021 where it tried to pass on a
whole load of risk it had taken on by
loaning money to
oligarchs and other ultra-rich customers
when they were buying private jets and
yachts boats and planes are obviously
risky assets they can be seized if you
get onto a sanctions list so credit
suisse was trying to syndicate and sell
the risk of financing some of these
assets out to hedge funds we published a
story which sort of laid bare some of
these transactions credit suisse got a
lot of flack from its clients on the
back of that credit suisse is obviously
upset and sends out an order to all of
their clients all the hedge funds they
were trying to sell the risk to asking
them to destroy the documents this was a
fairly innovative debt deal securitizing
this debt and passing it on to investors
who are willing to take on the risk and
it becomes misinterpreted by regulators
as an attempt for them to
destroy evidence and now they have to
explain to regulators in the u.s and
switzerland why they weren't attempting
to cover up their business with
sanctioned oligarchs
the remuneration system gives a wrong
incentive to the client relationship
manager trying to to to get some net new
money at any price risk-taking was in
fact rewarded it also doesn't appear to
have the right systems and checks and
balances we as an organization should
have better monitored and control
certain behaviors governance and the
risk management is for every financial
institution
critical and central if you're looking
at the future viability of its business
you've just got some of their top staff
in the investment bank in the wealth
management unit leaving they're fed up
because bonuses are being cut and it's
kind of franchise damaging like how long
you can can you survive if all of your
top people leave talent management is
absolutely a key we are continue to be
able to attract top-notch talent just
look to the caliber of
new members of the board we were able to
attract just look to the caliber of new
executives and the group executives you
were able to attract so people see the
current situation it's a great brand
it's a great franchise under pressure
with a lot of upside
in the year following the
twin collapses of archagus and greensell
credit suisse's share price halved the
bank said this is very much a transition
year and the clock is ticking over
whether the bank can come out of this
storm unscathed smp global has
downgraded trade suicide to a from a
plus credit suisse is likely to report
depressed results rundown of revenues
from investment banking businesses that
that they exit
and the fruits of restructuring are
still to come if it proves successful
credit suisse fully acknowledged that
the scandals were not just the result of
a couple of individuals going off on a
frolic i think that is the first step
actually towards rehabilitation actually
acknowledging that there is a bigger
issue we are in a very challenging
situation too many things have happened
over the last couple of years it's not
only about individual mistakes that have
happened that is something you need to
address from a systemic perspective from
an organizational perspective with axel
lemon we have a new chairman who knows
about risk management he was chief risk
officer of drake insurance and then he
led ubs space units a big bank with an
established global reputation decades
old is a very hard thing to kill a lot
of people think it will bounce back
changing the culture which is so deeply
embedded in the bank is going to be very
very hard work but that's not to say it
can't be achieved if you look at for
example example deutsche bank and ubs in
my estimates they will still reach a
profit this year but clearly it's market
dependent
it will take a number of years
to you know improve the reputation again
and there are also
tail risk pending from ongoing
litigations and investigations a lot of
parts of the bank are doing really great
we should not forget that it's not a
sprint it's more than a marathon it's
important that we do quarter by quarter
progress
the bank is very serious about changing
itself but it's like turning a super
tanker the question is whether the
amount of time that it's going to take
is as much time as credit suisse's
shareholders are willing to give the
executives you have taken very decisive
steps it starts at the top with the
board of directors
fifty percent of our members are new or
less than a year in their job we have
everywhere new committee chairs
including me as the new chairman we have
a brand new executive board with 11 out
of 13 members that are new shareholders
give us credit they believe in credit
space but we need to show progress
their ambitions would be to return to
profitability levels this is not
feasible over there foreseeable horizon
it's a very difficult time markets are
very volatile the situation in ukraine
with sanctions against russian
individuals and complete collapse of
business in russia which was integral to
a lot of private banking wealth here in
switzerland in challenging time when you
are under pressure as an organization
you can do things that normally you
can't do it's also an opportunity people
are watching to see what happens next
will it be bought will it be stripped of
its assets will it be folded into a
merger with ubs who's going to be buying
this bank at this time it's cheap but
it's cheap for a reason one option would
be
a spin-off of the swiss business the
question really is what happened to the
rest of the business there's too many
issues for a systemic bank to be taken
over neither domestically so a ubs
credit suisse merged nor international
u.s bank i think they will retain an
international business they have good
positions in my view let's say in asia i
think there is opportunity to grow uh on
on wealth management we have a
166 years old history and i'm a strong
believer that as an independent company
alongside other large banks in europe
and in switzerland that's the future of
the bank it remains
a group of strong international
franchise high diversification of
revenues
strong capital
and
high buffers of believable debt to
protect senior and secure creditors
we're not quite sure whether we've
reached the bottom of this yet because
every month every quarter every year
seems to bring
more scandal who's to say there won't be
another scandal brewing that we won't be
hearing about in a few weeks in a few
months time we went through a
fundamental review of all our risk
positions and legacy issues they
continue to pop up here and there but
i'm confident that we have bottom up and
we will bottom up and we will go step by
step into the right direction
come out of the mainstream station in
zurich there's a prominent statue of
alfred escher looking down the main
thoroughfare of the city if he was
looking at the bank today he would be
severely disappointed the perception of
charismas has obviously changed every
additional scandal that comes up the
reaction is kind of oh okay it's another
one oh yes of course it's crazy the
swiss parliament is very weak in
relative terms and the executive here
the federal council doesn't really like
to interfere there's a cultural attitude
in some of the banks and financial
institutions that maybe means something
can be dealt with quietly that's better
than having to admit it fully in public
problems end up sometimes getting stored
up over time because they are not nipped
in the bud and so you have as venerable
an institution as credit suisse having
suddenly to admit this whole slew of
scandals
secrecy is very important is very
ingrained in the swiss do not like their
dirty linen aired in public
[Music]
you